Og. Og. Not Pog. Pogu. So. Jetzt bin ich am Start. Moin Leute. Ah, Michael5strillionen auch wieder da. Hyperpog. Moment, gibt es das Emote? Das hat doch bestimmt schon irgendjemand, der ja natürlich wisst. Was sonst war, war klar.
Ja, wir machen heute 1-2 Aufgaben von den neuen. Ich bin mir nicht ganz sicher. Mein Brain ausreicht, mich da heute noch groß zu konzentrieren. Das werden wir wissen. Spätestens nach der ersten Aufgabe. Und dann machen wir weiter oder nicht. Muss man mal gucken.
Ansonsten guckt man noch irgendwie ein bisschen YouTube-Schwachsinn und dann Boomer-Müde-Boomer-Bett-Geh.
Wir sehen, wie scheiße das ist, wenn man auf dem Fahrrad umgefahren wird. Nicht so sehr, weil man umgefahren wird, sondern weil es wahrscheinlich ewig dauert, bis die Versicherung was bezahlt. Und man nicht weiß, ob man sich jetzt ein neues Fahrrad bestellen kann oder das alte noch repariert werden soll.
Ist richtig, richtig dämlich, Alter. Wer sich das ausgedacht hat, Mann. Du bist eigentlich als Umgefahrener doppelt am Arsch.
Frosty, GR. Danke schön für den Sub.
Ist richtig dämlich, Mann.
Ja, weiß ich nicht. Wahrscheinlich nirgendwo. Oder gar nicht. Bei nichts.
Das ist halt voll für den Arsch.
Also, ich habe jetzt die Auswahl. Entweder ich warte. Ist richtig, richtig weird, Champ.
Entweder ich warte halt jetzt irgendwie ein paar Monate, bis ich mir ein neues Fahrrad kaufe. Ob ich weiß, ob ich halt ein neues ersetzt kriege oder das alte repariert wird.
Ich gehe nicht davon aus, aber man weiß es ja nicht.
Oder ich kaufe mir auf gut Glück ein neues.
Oh, dann sagen sie, das alte wird doch repariert. Das ist so kacke, Alter.
Richtige Penner alles, Mann. So dumm. Richtig dumm.
Naja, zumindest das Gute ist, habe ich auch gerade gesagt, es ist kaputt.
Also, was heißt kaputt? Es hat halt verbogen das Rad. Ich war beim Gutachter, der hat sich das angeguckt.
Hat gesagt, hier, Carbonrahmen voll für den Arsch und ja, jetzt muss man mal gucken, was es kostet.
Was es kostet, wenn man das...
Wenn man das ersetzen würde und... Wahrscheinlich läufst du darauf raus, dass es neu ist.
Ja.
Ja, niemand nimmt dir den Carbonrahmen ab.
Ey, der hat Kratzer und hat Schläge abbekommen.
Niemand nimmt dir den Rahmen ab und sagt, es passt.
Rückgaberecht für was?
Nach Wohnfall, ja, ist klar.
Welchen Bürostuhl hast du?
Ich glaube, mach mal Ausrufezeichen Stuhl im Chat.
Ich glaube, wir haben sogar...
...einen...
...Link...
...zu meinem...
...Stuhl...
...irgendwo.
Probier mal, oder? Warte mal, ich probier das mal.
Ausrufezeichen Stuhl.
Ja, geht doch. Hier, guck, den hab ich.
Das Ding hier.
Hui.
Ah, dreht er sich.
Ja.
Besser.
Pog...
...Pog...
...Chair.
Das ist der Original Pogchair.
Das hört sich falsch an, wie rum.
Was ist passiert?
Ich bin auf dem Fahrradweg gefahren.
Leute, ich mach schon mal kurz die VM an.
Weil die VM braucht...
Wobei, brauchen wir die VM überhaupt?
Ja, doch, die VM brauchen wir.
Eigentlich brauchen wir die VM nicht, aber wir brauchen die VM.
Ja, VM wir jetzt nicht.
Was ist passiert? Also, ich bin auf dem Fahrradweg gefahren.
So wie man das...
...ja, eigentlich nicht...
...wie soll ich sagen...
...nicht besser machen kann als Fahrradfahrer.
Naja, besser als auf der Straße.
Ich bin auf dem Fahrradweg gefahren.
Und da gab es halt Ausfahrt.
Wobei das nicht wirklich eine Ausfahrt war.
Das war so ein...
...ja doch, eine Ausfahrt.
Ausfahrt trifft es, glaube ich, ganz gut.
Aber du hast komplett Vorfahrt auf dem Fahrradweg.
Und das siehst du auch, wenn man bei Google Maps guckt.
Dass die bei der Ausfahrt komplett Vorfahrt achten haben.
Inklusive Anzeige nochmal, dass es ein Fahrradweg ist.
Durchgestrichelte Linie um den Fahrradweg.
Und ich bin halt da vorbeigefahren.
Und bei der Ausfahrt ist einer rausgefahren.
Hat mich von der Seite umgefahren.
Und mir ist glücklicherweise nicht allzu viel passiert.
Ich war aber nochmal beim Doktor.
Und hab das dann zumindest aufnehmen lassen alles.
Also...
Also ich hab nicht wirklich körperlich großartig was, ja.
Wir haben die ersten paar Tage...
Es war am Samstag.
Wir haben die ersten paar Tage halt ein bisschen noch das Bein weh getan.
Und der Arm auf der einen Seite.
Ein bisschen der Hüfte hier auf der rechten Seite.
Merke ich es auch noch.
Ein bisschen der Rücken und so.
Aber das ging...
Und jetzt ist das eigentlich fast alles schon wieder weg.
Das dumme ist halt, dass das Fahrrad im Arsch ist.
Beziehungsweise das Fahrrad ist nicht richtig im Arsch.
Eigentlich denke ich, wenn man das Vorderrad...
Also doch.
Es ist auf jeden Fall im Arsch.
Also ich war ja beim Gutachter.
Und da hat er noch...
Der hat noch jede Menge neues Zeug gefunden.
Jetzt ist bloß die große Preisfrage.
Ob sich reparieren lohnt oder nicht.
Wahrscheinlich lohnt es sich nicht.
Weil sie den Rahmen eh austauschen müssen.
Aber es ist halt für den Arsch, ja.
Ich muss jetzt ewig warten.
Bis die ihren Kram da geschissen bekommen haben.
Bei der Versicherung.
Bis ich dann das Geld bekomme.
Weil ansonsten...
Ich kann mir halt nicht auf gut Glück ein neues Fahrrad kaufen.
Wenn ich auf gut Glück ein neues Fahrrad kaufe.
Und dem fällt dann doch ein...
Ach hier...
Ja lass mal lieber reparieren.
Dann habe ich zwei.
Ja.
So.
Und das Einzige...
Das Einzige was ich jetzt machen kann ist...
Ich kann das auf so einen Smart Trainer daheim stellen.
Da habe ich mir vor ein paar Tagen noch einen gekauft.
Noch bevor ich den Unfall hatte.
Witzigerweise.
Ganz gut ergeben.
Ich kann es jetzt halt nur noch daheim verwenden.
Ich habe das Ding vorhin aufgebaut.
Morgen mache ich mal das Fahrrad drauf.
Ist ja nicht so groß.
Und guck mal.
Ob man nicht auch im Wohnzimmer gescheit fahren kann.
Ja.
Einen Wahoo Kickr.
Richtig dummer Name, Alter.
Kickr.
Du kommst ja vor.
Wie in Zeiten, als das angesagt war.
Twitter hieß ja am Anfang auch Twitterr.
Und dann gab es Flickerr und so.
Das war eine Zeit lang voll angesagt.
Dass sich diese Dienste Krr hinten nennen.
Aber gut.
Das Ding macht einen ganz guten Eindruck.
War auf jeden Fall super easy aufzubauen.
Benutzt du...
Pogr.
Das finde ich auch gut.
Mich würde nicht wundern, wenn es das nicht sogar gäbe.
Irgendwo.
Pogr.
Suche ich jetzt nicht.
Man weiß ja nie, wo man da...
Ne.
Benutzt du irgendwelche Sites.
Benutzt du irgendwelche Cycling-Apps oder so.
Es gibt ja so ein paar Multiplayer-Apps sogar, wo man mit anderen Leuten da irgendwie rumfahren
kann.
Ja.
Na gut.
Das hat glaube ich gefühlt jeder.
Ja.
Das werde ich auch mal ausprobieren.
Aber es sagt halt einfach mal richtig.
Also war der Verursacher einsichtig?
Ja.
Die war übelst fertig.
Die war glaube ich noch fertiger als ich.
Ich bin der gar nicht so großartig böse.
Ja.
Ähm.
Was mich halt abfuckt ist, dass ich das jetzt so ewig habe.
Was mich halt abfuckt ist, dass sich das jetzt so ewig lang wahrscheinlich hinzieht.
Aber das einzig richtige war tatsächlich jetzt auch...
Das habe ich mir fast schon im Stream am Sonntag dann überlegt.
Oder Samstag?
Weiß ich gar nicht.
Ja doch.
Sonntag.
Dass ich mir jetzt einen Anwalt suche.
Dass ich mich nicht um den ganzen Kram kümmern muss und nichts verpassen.
Habe ich auch gemacht.
Ich habe mir einen Anwalt rausgesucht.
Und der kümmert sich jetzt darum.
Da hat er auch schon was hingeschickt.
Und...
Ich war beim Gutachter gestern.
Vorgestern.
Ne.
Gestern.
Ich war beim Gutachter.
Und der hat von allem Fotos gemacht.
Und meint halt das dauert immer ein bisschen.
Weil er muss jetzt erstmal online anfragen was die Preise sind für die Teile und so.
Ist halt...
Ah.
Autounfall.
Naja.
Wie man es nimmt.
Unfall mit einem Auto.
Ja.
Das stimmt.
Aber ich habe auf dem Fahrrad gesessen.
Ja.
Gehe ich auch von aus.
Das heißt aber.
Ich habe ein Auto.
Gehe ich auch von aus.
Das heißt aber nicht, dass es nicht dort trotzdem repariert wird.
Es könnte ja auch sein, dass jemand sagt.
Aha.
Der Rahmen kostet neu.
Keine Ahnung.
1500 Euro.
Und dann rechnet sich das ja.
Wenn man es reparieren lässt.
So.
Das ist halt für...
Also es ist ziemlich viel im Arsch.
Ja.
Der Rahmen ist im Arsch.
Der Lenker hat ein Schlagwerk.
Das ist auch...
Sogar das Sattel.
Sogar das Pedal.
Das habe ich alles gar nicht so...
Gar nicht auf den ersten Blick selbst gesehen.
Sogar die Schaltung ist verboten.
Bezahlst du den Anwalt selber?
Naja.
Ich hoffe mal, dass die Sache so klar ist, dass der von der Versicherung bezahlt wird
dann.
Aber eventuell muss ich es vielleicht selber erstmal bezahlen.
Aber die Sache ist...
Also aus meiner Sicht ist sie wirklich übelst, übelst klar.
Komplett vorgefahren und von der Seite umgefahren worden.
Also.
Was willst du noch machen?
Ja.
Was macht eigentlich der Tesla Truck?
Gibt es den mittlerweile?
Es gibt eine GTA 5.
Ja.
Das mache ich ja eh, wobei ich jetzt schon, ich war jetzt bestimmt fast, fast ne, naja nicht ganz, aber fast ne Woche nicht mehr rennen.
Das lag aber auch unter anderem daran, weil ich eigentlich vorhatte, okay, fähr Samstag, fährst du Fahrrad, musst nicht unbedingt alles am gleichen Tag machen.
Und nach dem Unfall hat mir dann halt erstmal das Bein weh getan, da wollte ich nicht rennen.
Also wahrscheinlich gehe ich morgen früh wieder.
Ist jetzt eigentlich alles soweit gut.
Ja, das war wahrscheinlich das Problem, dass ich auf dem Fahrrad, also ich suche mir ja immer, wenn ich die Routen plane, sei es jetzt bei Komoot oder mit Bike-Router oder so.
Übrigens, wer das nicht kennt, kann man echt empfehlen, Moment, ist das das Richtige überhaupt?
Weiß ich nicht, ähm, sieht irgendwie komisch aus.
Ja, aber das Ding, das Ding ist wirklich mega nice zum, zum Planen von Routen.
Man kann es natürlich, man...
Nein, nein, man kann es natürlich auch über Komoot oder so machen.
Das mache ich auch für Navigation am Ende dann.
Wobei ich das auch über den Fahrradcomputer machen kann, je nachdem.
Aber das, das ist wirklich mega, mega nice.
Vor allem hier die, die Profile, die man auswählen kann.
Also für Routenplanung ist das Ding wirklich nice.
Ja.
Und ich fahre halt hauptsächlich schon auf Fahrradwegen.
Leon, danke schön für den Sub.
Pog.
Ähm, ich...
Ich fahre hauptsächlich schon auf Fahrradwegen.
Ich fahre hauptsächlich schon auf Fahrradweg, weil ich keinen Bock habe, irgendwie da groß mich mit Autos zu koordinieren.
So nach dem Motto, gucken, ob irgendwie was von der Seite kommt.
Ja, gucken wir dann, wie wo rausfahren darf und sowas.
Und ausgerechnet auf dem fucking Fahrradweg erwischt es mich.
Ungefähr, ungefähr, ungefähr einen Monat, nachdem ich das neue Fahrrad habe, ist halt echt kacke.
Corporate Life ist anstrengend.
Wieso hast du einen neuen Job?
Habe ich heute auch gemerkt, dass Corporate Life anstrengend ist.
Business Enterprise stellt.
Da weiß man am Ende des Tages immer gar nicht, was eigentlich so...
Kennt ihr das auch auf der Arbeit?
Dass ihr euch so manchmal denkt, mittags, nachmittags, so, ey, das war heute echt anstrengend.
Und da überlegt ihr euch, was habt ihr eigentlich gemacht?
Und im Endeffekt habt ihr eigentlich nichts gemacht.
Aber es war trotzdem anstrengend.
Ja, nee, das ist...
Pog-Subscription.
Ich lasse Garmin gar nicht routen.
Ich plane über Komoot oder Bike-Router.
Ich lade dann auf das Garmin, also über die Garmin Connect App, die Route und habe im Garmin Routenplanung und automatisches Anpassen der Route ausgeschaltet.
Weil das ist so kacke, dieses Routing.
Ich weiß gar nicht, wie man so kacke sein kann beim Routing.
Eigentlich war Garmin doch einer der ersten mit Navigationsgeräten.
Die müssten so eigentlich hinklingen.
Also Garmin ist super zum Anzeigen und so.
Aber Routing darüber...
Also eine feste Route ist zum Anzeigen.
Aber wirklich Route planen darauf, beziehungsweise...
Das ist das Unplant, wenn du irgendwie vom Kurs ab...
Das ist so schlecht, Alter.
Ja, das stimmt schon.
Aber eins muss man sagen.
Komoot ist bei mir der Meister drin, zu sagen, now make a U-Turn.
Das ist so dämlich teilweise.
Du hast was...
Machen wir mal...
Machen wir mal so, hier, guck.
Es geht hier einen Weg.
Es geht hier einen Weg und es geht irgendwie...
So.
Warte mal, was ist...
Was ist freiheitlich so?
Und es geht irgendwie noch so einen Weg.
So, und wenn du...
Und wenn du...
Hier lang fährst, so.
Dum-dum-dum-dum.
Fährst hier lang.
Dum-dum-dum.
So, und dann hast du dich irgendwie verguckt.
Und fährst an...
Du wolltest hier lang.
Eigentlich, das hier ist die geplante Route hier, ja.
So, aber du fährst hier lang.
Dann sagt Komoot an der Stelle...
Now make a U-Turn.
Und dann fährst du weiter.
Now make...
Ah, okay, jetzt kannst du auch hier weiter.
Anstatt einfach gleich zu sagen, Alter, die 5 Meter kannst du auch hier mal um die Ecke fahren.
Ja, das ist teilweise auch schon echt bescheuert.
Aber allemal besser als das Umrouten von Garmin.
Garmin lasse ich nicht umrouten.
Da habe ich alles ausgeschaltet.
Ne.
Ne, ne, ne, ne.
Ich lade die Strecke.
Über die Garmin-App lade ich die Strecke da drauf.
Und ich navigiere über die Default-Map.
Und navigiere über das Garmin.
Und wenn ich irgendwas nicht finde, weil das Garmin-Pepega-Zeug anzeigt,
ich habe vorne auf meinem Lenker einen Clip.
Also keinen Clip, sondern so einen...
Ich kann es euch zeigen.
Gerade, komm.
Die 10 Minuten vom Anfang haben wir auch.
Ich habe vorne so einen SP-Connect.
So einen Mount drauf bei mir am Lenker.
Also nicht am Lenker, oben am Lenker.
Ich weiß nicht, ob die da ein Bild dabei haben.
Ja.
Guck.
Da kannst du diesen Knopf oben am Lenker austauschen.
Durch den hier den Knopf...
Äh, Leute, warum habe ich eigentlich immer noch das gleiche 10 Stunden hier gedudelt?
Wir müssen mal ein bisschen was an...
Relaxing Music.
Excellent.
Hyper-Relaxing Music.
Sehr schön.
Ja.
Und da kannst du das Handy drauf machen hier.
Und wenn das Garmin gar zu Pepega ist,
das ist halt wirklich...
Richtig nice Position.
Da wackelt es nicht irgendwie am Lenker rum.
Das ist halt wirklich nice.
Und wenn das Garmin so krass Pepega ist,
dass es nicht damit klarkommt,
beziehungsweise es ist irgendwas gesperrt
und ich muss irgendwas umfahren,
dann mache ich das Handy an.
Das hängt ja eh schon drauf.
Ja.
Dann gucke ich einfach ins Handy rein,
mache den Bildschirm hoch
und gucke auf Komoot drauf,
beziehungsweise starte das an der Stelle
und darf mich Komoot kurz umruten
und danach fahre ich mit dem Garmin weiter.
Das ist richtig...
Also...
Leider gibt es irgendwie da keine perfekte Lösung für.
Oder ich habe es noch nicht gefunden.
Wie gesagt, ich habe die Default Map.
Was macht ihr eigentlich?
Sind wir eigentlich noch eingeloggt?
Aber wir sind noch eingeloggt.
Pock, da können wir gleich weitermachen.
Leute, ich habe nämlich gesehen,
das hier ist auch neu.
Das haben wir noch gar nicht gemacht.
Easy.
Garmin verkaufen.
Nee, das Ding ist...
Das Ding macht deutlich mehr als das Handy.
Das ist schon nice,
den Fahrradcomputer vorne dran zu haben.
Also aus mehreren Gründen.
Erstens,
wenn du mal wirklich länger fährst,
sagen wir mal drei Stunden und so,
dann hält das Handy so lange nicht durch.
Immer volle Displayhelligkeit,
immer Navigation an.
Die Handys sind relativ schnell leer.
Selbst wenn du bei 100% startest,
ich meine,
dann hast du vielleicht noch ein bisschen Saft drin,
aber nach drei Stunden
Bildschirmhelligkeit
und komplett Navigation offen,
die verlieren ziemlich schnell Akku schon.
So.
Das ist halt das Dumme,
warum du das nicht permanent mit dem Handy machen kannst.
Und außerdem,
und außerdem,
und das wirst du ja hier wahrscheinlich auch haben.
Dafür hast du halt,
dafür hast du halt am Garmin noch die ganzen Anzeigegeschichten
von Kilometer,
Power,
Herzfrequenz,
Berg,
Dingsprofil und alles möglich.
Ist eigentlich schon ganz nice.
Das Ding finde ich auch cool.
Was ich ein bisschen doof fand,
ist,
dass die wohl irgendwie Probleme hatten
mit Shimano
und deswegen die,
wie spricht man das eigentlich aus,
die i2-Geschichten,
die ich eben nicht mehr richtig integrieren kann,
nur über Plug-In.
Nicht Uhr.
Der Fahrradcomputer von Garmin.
Naja.
Aber an sich finde ich es eigentlich ganz nice.
Mir gefällt das Setup jetzt echt.
Ich habe leider kein aktuelles Bild von.
Also ich habe es jetzt so gemacht.
Ich habe es jetzt so gemacht.
Ich habe drei Sachen vorne dran.
Ich habe einen Halter für das Garmin am Lenker.
Da ist das Garmin dran.
Und unten drunter hat es einen Halter für eine Lampe,
falls ich echt mal eine Lampe brauche.
Ja.
Ja, genau.
Das habe ich auch gelesen.
Dann habe ich
oben dran dieses,
dieses Mount hier fürs Handy,
falls ich das Handy wirklich brauche.
Am Lenker, hier vorne das Mount.
Und auf der anderen Seite
habe ich nochmal einen Mount,
das kann man aber so schräg hier stellen,
für eine Kamera.
Weil ja, boah,
dachten wir ab und zu kann ich ja mal ein bisschen was aufnehmen.
Und das passt echt ganz gut.
Das war auch alles dran,
als ich gecrashed bin,
letztens da.
Aber es ist gecrashed.
Ich bin nicht gecrashed.
Ich wurde umgecrashed, ja.
Ich wurde umgefahren.
Das Equipment, das
blieb wirklich gut dran.
Nee, Radstream mache ich nicht.
Das dressiert doch kein Mensch hier.
Ja, die Leute wollen hier ein bisschen
sinnlosen Technik-Talk auf Twitch.
Also was ich mir schon überlegt habe,
was ich mal just for fun,
also als Bonus-Stream machen könnte.
Ich mache mal auf Swift,
mache ich mal so einen Ramp-Test.
Da könnt ihr mich abkacken sehen bei.
Okay.
Muss ich mal gucken.
Also ich werde das Ding morgen aufbauen.
Den Smart-Trainer zusammengebaut,
habe ich schon.
Morgen mache ich mal das Fahrrad drauf.
Dann mache ich vielleicht echt mal so einen Test.
Da werde ich abkacken bei.
Einen Wahoo Kikr.
Bester Name.
Kikr.
Man kann es einfach Kikr aussprechen.
Aber eigentlich müsste man es Kikr aussprechen.
Ja, keins eigentlich.
Offiziell, ne?
Na doch, ich habe ein Rad.
Aber offiziell ist es ja,
darf man es nicht benutzen.
Und ich werde es auch auf der Straße nicht mehr benutzen.
Ne, einen Monat habe ich das Fahrrad.
Genau einen Monat.
Oder über den Monat.
Ich darf mein Fahrrad nicht mehr auf der Straße benutzen.
Weil ich einen Unfall hatte letzten Samstag.
Und sogar der Gutachter sagt,
der Rahmen ist wahrscheinlich im Arsch.
Und ich habe keinen Bock,
dass mein Fahrrad auseinander bricht,
während ich auf der Straße unterwegs bin.
Ja.
So, wo sind wir denn jetzt eigentlich stehen geblieben?
Was ist denn das hier?
Ach, das ist das Datenbankzeug.
Machen wir mal alles zu hier.
Alles weg.
So, wir fangen heute mit etwas Einfachem an, Leute.
Easy.
Ja.
Com-Knocking.
Ne.
In Tai-P.
Ist das Taiwan?
Das werden wir heute anfangen.
Wir machen heute mal easy.
Nachdem ich mir das letzte Mal echt schwer getan habe mit Paris.
Gucken wir mal.
Für alle, die das letzte Mal nicht dabei waren,
ich erkläre gleich, um was es geht.
Genau, das ist das Fahrrad.
Also, was ich mir jetzt überlegt habe, ist,
wenn das Fahrrad jetzt ja eh im Arsch ist,
und ich da eh noch ein paar Monate drauf warten muss,
bis das...
Guck mal, es gibt es sogar reduziert mittlerweile.
Gibt es da noch in meiner Größe?
Warte mal, vielleicht den grünen?
Ha, gibt es tatsächlich nur in meiner Größe.
Na gut.
Was wollte ich jetzt sagen?
Ja, also, wenn ich da jetzt eh vielleicht noch ein paar Monate drauf warte,
dann ist das Fahrrad.
Dann ist das Fahrrad.
Wenn ich jetzt drauf warten muss, bis die Versicherung...
Ich hoffe ja nicht, ja.
Bis die Versicherung das Geld bezahlt.
Oder die Reparatur.
Aber, naja.
Gucken wir mal.
Vielleicht gibt es bis dahin noch ein paar andere.
Weil, nachdem ich das Fahrrad jetzt einen Monat gefahren bin,
es gibt schon so ein paar Sachen, wo ich mir denke,
hey, ein paar Sachen wären echt ganz nice noch.
Also, das elektronische Schalten finde ich mega nice.
Vor allem, dass man zwei Bedienknöpfe für die Technik hat.
Und, nochmal zusätzlich.
Man hat ja links und rechts Knöpfe dafür.
Nochmal am Lenker, die man pairen kann.
Da musst du nicht rumtatschen auf dem Display, während man fährt.
Das ist eigentlich nice.
Ah ja, wenn schon, dann richtig.
Irgendwo muss die Kohle ja hin.
Weiß ich nicht.
Ich kenne die neuen Räder nicht.
Ich kenne...
Weiß ich nicht.
Habe ich nicht.
Muss ich mal gucken, was da so vorgestellt wurde.
Also, was ich ja beispielsweise noch ganz gerne hätte, ist...
Ich bin mir auch nicht sicher, ob ich bei...
Das ist ja das Letzte.
Wir müssen jetzt irgendwann mal anfangen, weil sonst wird das heute nichts mehr.
Was wollte ich denn jetzt sagen?
Ja, ich bin mir gar nicht sicher, ob mir das Shimano-Ökosystem so gut gefällt.
Weil da ist ja alles super speziell.
Das eine geht nur mit dem und exakt mit dem und das andere ist nicht supported.
Und auch sogar das Funkprotokoll ist komplett closed source.
Ich meine, gut funktioniert hat es.
Gut funktioniert hat es schon, muss man sagen.
Ich hätte vielleicht noch ganz gerne einen leichteren Gang.
Und dementsprechend, vielleicht gibt es nächstes Jahr halbwegs zu so einem ähnlichen Preis schon ein Zwölffachsystem.
Dann...
Dann irgendwie was mit, keine Ahnung...
44 oder so.
Irgendwie 10, 44 oder irgendwas.
Ja, mal gucken.
Ja, ich kenne die ganzen Videos.
Ist so ein Preis gerechtfertigt?
Das kommt immer darauf an, was du haben willst.
Also...
Es ist wie bei vielem, du kriegst für die ersten paar Euro meistens das meiste für dein Geld.
Also, wenn du einfach nur ein Fahrrad suchst, wo du auf die Arbeit fahren kannst, wo du von A nach B kommst,
da kannst du dir irgendwie für 500, 600 Euro was kaufen und bestimmt auch super happy damit sein.
Wenn man noch ein paar zusätzliche Sachen will und halt auch ein bisschen mehr Spaß an sowas hat,
dann lohnt es sich schon.
Dann...
Ich meine, man braucht kein...
Ich bin jetzt bei weitem nicht der Fahrrad-Experte, ja, muss ich auch sagen.
Wie gesagt, ich habe mir das neue erst auch vor einem Monat oder knapp über einem Monat,
ein bisschen, ein paar Tage über einem Monat gekauft.
Also, wenn man zum Beispiel elektronische Schaltung haben will, was ich jetzt echt richtig nice finde,
nachdem ich das einen Monat gefahren bin und jetzt leider nicht mehr fahren kann,
kostet es auf jeden Fall schon mal mehr.
Dann gibt es ja quasi so diesen kontinuierlichen Anstieg von Alurahmen, Alurahmen mit Carbon-Gabel zu Carbon-Rahmen,
wenn man das haben will, kostet auch noch mal mehr.
Dann gibt es da das Felgenbremsen, Scheibenbremsen, je nachdem, was man haben will.
Und wenn du da alles mögliche...
Dann geht es weiter mit Aluräder, Carbonräder, Tubeless oder nicht.
Also, wenn du irgendwelche Kombinationen haben willst, dann wird es halt auch ein bisschen teurer.
Aber wenn du einfach nur was suchst, wo du von A nach B kommst,
dann spricht auch nichts dagegen, sich was deutlich günstigeres zu kaufen.
Na gut.
Dann gehen wir mal zu den...
Warum willst du nicht?
Ich auch nicht, ich auch nicht, aber bis jetzt nicht.
Ich meine, ich finde ja die Idee, die ich jetzt ein paar Mal im Internet gesehen habe,
schon in Videos, eigentlich nicht schlecht.
Man rüstet das auf Tubeless um, weil die meisten Reifen, die man so bekommt, sind ja mittlerweile schon ready.
Da muss man ja nur ein bisschen Klebermilch reinfüllen.
Und braucht ein anderes Ventil, glaube ich.
Aber...
Man kann ja trotzdem noch einen Schlauch mitnehmen, im Fall der Fälle, falls echt was so kaputt ist.
Das fand ich eigentlich ganz, ganz sinnig.
Also, das muss ich mir noch überlegen.
Aber erstmal brauche ich hier ein neues Fahrrad.
So, aber wir fangen jetzt an, Leute.
Auf geht's.
Ich erkläre euch jetzt nochmal kurz...
Oder, Chatke, Frage, Frage an euch.
War irgendjemand von euch nicht dabei in einem der letzten Set-Server-Streams?
Wenn ja, dann erzähle ich nochmal zwei Minuten, um was es dabei geht.
Oh, die Musik ist mir deutlich zu entspannt.
Ich muss mal kurz ein bisschen...
Ein bisschen was zackigeres machen.
Hier kommt ein bisschen Wupp-Wupp.
Wupp-Wupp.
Wupp-Wupp-Wupp, genau.
Dü-dü-dü-dü-dü.
Wupp-Wupp-Wupp-Wupp-Wupp.
Ein bisschen laut noch.
So.
Oh, ist gut.
Okay, also, wart ihr alle dabei?
Ich glaube es ja nicht, weil viele Leute schreiben es nicht.
Also, ganz kurz gesagt.
Set-Servers ist eine Webseite von...
Oder ein Service von einem...
Ich glaube von einem deutschen Entwickler.
Weil er hat auch auf Twitter schon öfters mal was auf Deutsch gepostet.
Also vermutlich auch vom deutschen Entwickler.
Da geht es darum, dass man verschiedene kaputte Linux-Server vorgesetzt bekommt,
die man reparieren muss.
Wobei das nur die halbe Wahrheit ist.
Es gibt verschiedene Kategorien.
Also, irgendwas reparieren, irgendwas erledigen oder halt irgendwas knacken.
Das ist im Prinzip der Hintergedanke davon.
Das ist ein bisschen sowas wie Hacking-CTF.
Hacking-CTFs.
Und nach dem Motto...
Manche Sachen gehen auch in die Richtung.
So nach dem Motto hier.
Du hast einen Web-Server mit Authentifizierung und auf dem Server liegt unter etc. irgendeine Datei.
Was steht in der Datei drin?
Oder sowas.
Also, manches geht in die Richtung.
Und es gibt verschiedene Aufgaben.
Von einfach über mittel bis schwer.
Manche Aufgaben in schwer sind auch wirklich nicht ohne.
Und sogar manche Aufgaben in mittel.
Sind schon echt nicht ohne.
Hier bei dem hier hatte ich letztens echt mal eine Probleme.
Auf die Sache mit dem...
Ne, warte mal.
Ja.
Auf die Sache mit dem User-Agent bin ich einfach nicht gekommen.
Dabei ist das total naheliegend.
Ja.
Ich zeige euch einfach mal ganz kurz, wie es funktioniert.
Nochmal, das dauert auch nur zwei Minuten, bevor es losgeht.
Wir dürfen hier eine Sache nicht vergessen.
Wieder...
Ah.
Geheimnis-Terminal oben drüber.
Weil ansonsten wird geleakt.
Ja.
Also, hier seht ihr es.
Die Aufgabe ist rauszufinden, welcher Prozess in var log bedlog schreibt.
Und da sieht man, hier schreibt irgendwas rein.
Wir sollen rausfinden, welcher Prozess da reinschreibt.
Und den Prozess beten.
Das ist in dem Fall natürlich relativ easy.
Da gucken wir nach.
Okay.
Es ist hier ein Pfeilhändel auf mit PID 5850.
Da können wir sagen, kill 585 und jetzt ist das Ganze gefixt.
Das ist aber ja auch...
Das ist die allererste easy-Aufgabe.
Also, denkt nicht, dass die alle so einfach sind.
Und dann sagt man am Ende, check my solution.
Und dann sagt er, hey, hat funktioniert.
Also, so funktioniert das.
Nur, dass die Aufgaben echt schwierig werden mit der Zeit.
Deswegen machen wir heute mal eine easy-Aufgabe.
Da könnt ihr alle mitmachen.
Wer von euch ist...
Chat geben, mal eine Frage.
Wer von euch ist im Linux-Umfeld tätig?
Oder ihr müsst damit jetzt nicht wirklich euer täglich Brot verdienen,
aber einfach nur...
Benutzt ihr Linux?
Arbeitet ihr mit Linux?
Habt ihr irgendwie arbeitstechnisch was damit zu tun?
Weil wenn ja, dann könnt ihr jetzt ein bisschen mitraten.
Oder mit...
Mit backseaten.
Ups, was ist jetzt?
Flashbang.
Ich weiß ja.
Windows-Enjoyer.
Gut.
So, wir machen jetzt eine einfache Aufgabe.
Ich hoffe auch, dass die einfach ist.
Dass da nicht einfach dran steht.
Weil die haben wir noch gar nicht gemacht.
Du benutzt Arch, ja, dann kann ja nichts schief gehen.
Du musst es aber ein bisschen offensiver den Leuten erzählen, dass du Arch benutzt.
Das war ein bisschen...
Das war ein bisschen selten, ja.
Ich gucke mir gerade deine letzten Chat-Messages an.
Das ist jetzt hier Exposed.
Und du hast 154 Chat-Messages geschrieben.
Und du hast einmal nur geschrieben, dass du Arch benutzt hast.
Ich nutze Arch, by the way.
Das ist für einen Arch-User deutlich...
Deutlichst zu wenig.
Das muss man eigentlich bei jeder Gelegenheit erwähnen.
Ja, ja, gut.
Support.
Nee, noch nicht durchgespielt.
Tatsächlich, ich habe nämlich gesehen, es gibt sogar auch nicht nur in Medium und Schwer neue Aufgaben,
sondern auch in Easy.
Die haben wir noch gar nicht gemacht.
Was ich ein bisschen doof finde, das sollte ich ihm vielleicht auch mal aufklären.
Auf Twitter schreiben.
Warum gibt es keine Release-Zeit der Aufgaben mehr, nachdem man sortieren kann?
So weiß ich gar nicht, ob ich das gemacht habe, wenn ich nicht gerade eingeloggt bin mit dem Account.
Endeavor OS ist erlaubt, Arch-User zu sein.
Manjaro nicht.
Ist auch ganz logisch.
Endeavor OS benutzt die ganz normalen Arch-Repos.
Manjaro nicht.
Manjaro hat ihre eigenen Repos.
Allein schon deswegen ist Manjaro kein Arch, by the way.
Gut, dann legen wir mal los.
Info.
Was müssen wir hier machen?
Taipei.
Ist das in Taiwan?
Das interessiert mich jetzt.
No, God!
No, God, please, no!
No!
Okay, Leute.
Ich habe keine Ahnung, wie der Account und das Passwort war hierfür.
Also, wenn es ein Inkognito-Tab ist, ist es ein Inkognito-Tab?
Sieht man das irgendwo?
Dann sind wir jetzt...
Dann haben wir jetzt gelitten.
Nee, wir sind noch eingeloggt.
Okay, alles gut.
Also, was sollen wir machen?
Genau, ich wollte gucken, wozu Taipei gehört.
Taiwan, ja.
Hat noch BSD im Einsatz.
Ich glaube, dass in manchen Bereichen BSD echt beliebt ist.
Man trifft wenige BSD-User.
Also, die Playstation basiert ja auf Re-BSD, glaube ich.
Oder OpenBSD.
Nee, OpenBSD.
Oder?
Ach, keine Ahnung, auf was die Playstation-Firma basiert.
Aber es gibt Bereiche, da ist BSD, glaube ich, echt beliebt.
Man trifft wenige hauptsächliche BSD-Users.
Ich glaube, dass, ehrlich gesagt, dass FreeBSD generell bei so ganz hardcore Internet-Service-Provider-Leuten verbreitet ist.
Nee, ich glaube, Trunas ist mittlerweile auch Linux.
Ja, also, ich würde beispielsweise...
Ich würde mich auf jeden Fall nicht wundern, wenn die weltweiten Root-DNS-Server auf BSD laufen.
Ich weiß es nicht, ob sie es machen, aber ich würde es auf jeden Fall nicht wundern.
Das sind so Dinge, wo ich denke, in dem Bereich ist BSD noch beliebt.
Und vielleicht auch...
Vielleicht halt auch in dem ein oder anderen Embedded-Bereich.
Da kenne ich mich aber zu wenig mit aus.
Weiß ich nicht.
Ich meine, Linux ist eindeutig das Verbreitete.
Ja, das ist schon klar.
So, dann legen wir mal los.
Run.
Also, was ist denn jetzt eigentlich...
Ich habe eigentlich die Aufgabe immer noch nicht richtig gelesen, ja.
Was ist denn die Aufgabe?
Come a knocking.
Level easy.
Okay, Leute, das müssen wir easiest schaffen.
Also, Description.
Okay, es gibt...
Also, es läuft dort ein Web-Server auf Port 80.
Protected with Port-Knocking.
Alter, wie lange habe ich kein Port-Knocking mehr gesehen?
Das ist locker schon 10 Jahre her.
Ich wusste gar nicht, dass das irgendjemand noch benutzt.
Habt ihr die letzten 10 Jahre mal Port-Knocking verwendet?
Hä?
Das ist schon wirklich sehr lange her.
Find the one knock needed.
Send a SYN-Package to a single port, not a sequence.
So you can curl local hosts.
Okay, also ich vermute mal, das soll mir Folgendes sagen.
Es gibt ein Web-Server auf Port 80.
Allerdings ist Port 80 Standard.
Mäßig nicht offen.
Erst wenn ich vorher an den richtigen Port ein SYN-Package geschickt habe.
Weißt du, wir reden hier auch nur von TCP.
Dann geht der Port auf und ich kann es curlen.
Vermute ich mal.
Alter, es ist ewig her, wo ich was mit Port-Knocking gemacht habe.
Also wirklich richtig lange.
Netznet, lass uns mal gucken.
Also, wie viel...
Leute, wir müssen mal meinen Timer etwas...
Meinen Timer etwas usen.
Wie viel Zeit haben wir?
15 Minuten.
Okay, oh, bam.
Timer.
Also, wir haben ein...
Web-Server auf 80.
Okay, curl local hosts.
Na gut, den Port können wir uns sparen.
Failed.
Okay, jetzt müssen wir Port-Knocking machen.
Ich habe legit keinen Plan, wie das geht.
Ein SYN-Package senden.
Das kann man auch bestimmt wunderbar mit NetCap machen.
Keine Ahnung.
Kann man nicht irgendwie sowas machen wie NetCap, was weiß ich, SYN-only oder so?
Ah ja.
Okay, hier gibt es eine Erklärung.
Okay.
NC-Z.
NC-Z, Local Hosts und dann irgendwie Port 1000 und so.
Okay.
Das knockt jetzt, ja?
Ich hoffe, dass das jetzt funktioniert.
Ja, wir können ja mal gucken.
Netznet, Grab.
Nee.
Müsste man das, müsste man das, wenn es ein SYN-Package geschickt hätte?
Ach, nicht 80.000, 1000.
Nicht eigentlich sehen.
Ach so, wahrscheinlich, weil das direkt abgebaut wurde, weil da nichts läuft, ha?
Oder weiß die Parameter für nicht.
Okay, also wir müssen ein SYN-Package schicken.
An...
Ja, wir wissen nicht, an welchen Port.
Okay, äh...
Wisst ihr was?
Können wir nicht einfach sowas machen?
Vor I in...
Ich rate jetzt einfach mal 1 bis 65.000...
Oh, Chat-Gill.
65.536...
Nee, oder?
Warte mal.
65.535...
Ah, fuck it.
Also, 2 hoch...
Äh, 2 hoch 32...
Nee, nicht 2 hoch 32.
Äh, 2 hoch 16.
2, 5, 5, 3...
Ja, ist doch richtig.
Ja, also, ich weiß, dass es irgendwie was in dem Dreh ist,
aber genau wissen tue ich es auch nicht.
Wir machen...
Wir probieren das mal.
Wir machen einfach eine Schleife...
Minus 1, das wurscht jetzt.
Wir machen einfach...
Aber du hast recht.
Wir machen einfach mal eine Schleife.
So, Netcat.
Minus Z, weil es der Gauferflow das sagt.
Und der Gauferflow hat bei sowas immer recht.
Du, Adcat.
Auf diesen Port, dann.
Machen wir nochmal ein Echo davor, dass wir wissen, wo wir sind.
Äh.
Achso, Du hab ich vergessen.
Hä?
What the fuck?
Vor, I, in?
Ach.
Da hinten ist noch ein Du.
Das hat da nix zu suchen.
Okay.
Oh, das dauert jetzt aber eine ganze Weile.
Ob das jetzt...
Nmap instead.
Ja gut, mit...
Also mit Nmap würde mich nicht...
Würde mich nicht wundern, wenn das funktioniert.
Mit Nmap kannst du ja irgendwie gefühlt fast alles machen.
In dieser Richtung.
Gab es nicht...
Also wie gesagt, das ist schon 10 Jahre locker her, wo ich Portnocking mal was gemacht hab.
Gab es nicht da sogar ein eigenes Programm für so einen eigenen CLI-Client?
Okay, da muss ich mal kurz gucken.
Linux, Port, Portnocking.
Ey, ja, Arch, by the way.
Die wissen da Bescheid.
Introduction.
Guck mal hier.
Nmap.
Vielleicht geht's jetzt auch einfach.
Simples.
Noc D.
Ja.
Das habe ich benutzt.
Das kommt mir sehr bekannt vor.
Gab es nicht zu Noc D?
Okay, vielleicht ist das auch einfach nur ein Alias.
Weil ich bilde mir ein, es gab...
ein Programm, was sich Noc nannte.
Aber vielleicht ist das auch einfach nur ein Alias.
Das kann natürlich auch sein, wenn das nur...
Aber netcat-z ist schon mal nicht verkehrt, was wir machen.
Naja, ich bin mir ehrlich gesagt nicht sicher, ob die VM das verkraftet,
wenn ich 65.000 Background-Jobs starte.
Die kackt bestimmt ab dabei.
Wir können es zum Schluss probieren, Leute, wenn ihr wollt.
Wir können es gleich probieren, ob die das...
Näh, wenn die abkackt, dann muss ich das neu starten.
Ja, dann erinnert mich dran, Leute.
Erinnert mich dran, dass wir gucken, ob es abkackt.
Ja, ja, Portname ist...
Okay, curl, localhost.
Easy, fertig.
Hat funktioniert.
Ha, okay, das war einfach.
Easy as fuck.
Easy.
Welcher Port war es denn?
Eine sehr gute Frage, welcher Port es war.
Das wissen wir so nicht.
Ha.
Um das rauszufinden, müssten wir eigentlich so...
Okay, Chatgear, um rauszufinden, welcher Port es war...
Also das können wir jetzt nicht mal machen, weil der Port ist auf.
Es sei denn, der geht irgendwie nach ein, zwei Minuten und so wieder zu.
Okay.
Hier noch ein Curl machen.
Und dann sagen localhost, Port.
Doppelpunkt, Port.
Ne, Quatsch, was mache ich denn?
Einfach nur 80.
Blödsinn.
Und wenn Curl funktioniert, dann Break.
Ja.
Das Problem ist jetzt, dass wir das nicht machen können, weil es ist ja schon da.
Können wir den Web-Server irgendwie neu starten oder so?
Netztern.
Was läuft denn da?
Ne, das läuft auf Root, weil es Pod 80 ist
Nö, dann
Was ist diese Und-Und-Magie?
Das ist ein If
Zeige ich dir jetzt mal bei mir auf der Shell, das kann man dann ein bisschen schöner zeigen
Also, zum Beispiel kannst du sagen
Wir machen mal Echo
Echo 1, 2, 3
So, dann kannst du sagen
Wenn dieses Programm erfolgreich ist
Dann, okay, machen wir es anders
Wir machen es ganz easy
True
Wenn das Programm erfolgreich ist, dann sagen wir okay
Oder wir sagen Fehler
So, jetzt kommt okay raus
Ist das Programm
Return Code
Ungleich
Warte mal, Bash Return Codes sind immer umgedreht, gell
Äh, 0 ist true in Bash
Und alles andere ist false, oder?
Ja doch, genau
Genau, bei Exit Code 0
Kommt Fehler raus
Das ist quasi ein kurzes If
Das heißt, wenn man
Irgendwie sowas macht
Curl, keckel, Punkt, keck
Dann sagt er Fehler
Weil es gibt es nicht
Und wenn man sagt, curl.google.de
Dann ist okay
So, wenn wir Glück haben, geht das mit der Zeit
Wieder zu, der Port
Aber sieht nicht so aus
Okay, ähm, Chat
Dann machen wir folgendes
Wir haben jetzt noch zwei Sachen
Zu testen bei dieser Aufgabe
Wir sagen jetzt, check my solution
Okay, die ist richtig
Dann loggen wir uns aus, machen das zu
Starten das neu
Und dann probieren wir mal aus
Mit dem Curl hintendran
Dass wir wissen, welcher Port es war
Und dann starten wir 65.000 Prozesse
Ich glaube nicht, dass das funktioniert
Der hat garantiert irgendwelche Lippen
Wobei, ganz ehrlich, der braucht keine Limits
Weil die VM limitiert ja genug
Es sind halt ganz kleine
Lippen, die wir haben
AWS Instanzen
Also, im Endeffekt sind das sogar
Shared AWS Instanzen
Das heißt, je weniger du machst, wahrscheinlich umso billiger ist es
Also, vermutlich
Gibt es Limits
Auf den Kisten
Schauen wir mal, gucken wir gleich mal
Aber vorher will ich mal gucken, ob da meine
Curl Magic funktioniert
Hier, let's go
Ja
Dann ist das Limit instant weg
Müsste da Linux nicht von sich aus bremsen?
Wie gesagt, wenn Limits gesetzt sind, ja wenn nicht, nein
Also, ja Standardmäßig, die Standardlimits, aber die sind so hoch die jucken keinen
Bei sowas, ich weiß gar nicht, was die Standardlimits überhaupt sind
Als es überhaupt welche gibt, das ist eine gute Frage, ich weiß nicht
Selbst wenn er nur 100 kann, wird es zehnmal schneller
Nein, das Problem ist, dass du in Bash dann quasi eine Art Multithreading machen musst
Weil, der wird bestimmt nicht einfach nur sich begnügen mit 100
sondern wir müssten da irgendwie so einen wait einbauen oder sowas weiß nicht ob wait das in
bash kann so nach dem motto wait auf 100 background prozesse wait ach nee was hat ein wait so
eingebaut so also jetzt wir probieren jetzt erstmal aus ob das hier funktioniert was ich
da gebaut habe ich glaube dass das etwas zu schnell geht dass der port vielleicht noch
nicht da ist ich fürchte so werden weg als viel zu lahm so lange warte ich nicht guck mal der
müsste 65.000 ports durchprobieren das dauert auf jeden fall zu lang dass man kann machen okay dass
der war es auf jeden fall nicht wie können wir wie können wir okay lass mal lass mal feiert heim
walten so als problem war erst mal das aus was der chat
eben ausprobieren wollte mit background ich glaube dass das funktioniert was war das in
hintergrund machen oder ich glaube man darf kein glaube so geht das nicht mehr genau das
ist ganz wird man braucht man darf kein komma irgendwie machen wir könnten das auch mal
klammern und dann in background schicken wow ist für uns nicht
auch keine ahnung also man kann man kann er in bash auf jeden fall sagen wait dann müssen wir aber
das glaube ich wegmachen aber wait ist jetzt halt bis die background klammern also wir müssten das
quasi wir müssten das irgendwie hundert mal starten und dann war und dass es halt für ein
arsch naja wir können das also du f hält mir jetzt im bash pauschalen nichts gescheites ein ein course
weARYet limit cuk peace pich fallen survivors weary nnt exclusive sequence game kinderacity
100 Jobs.
Hier, Bash Limit Number of Concurrent Jobs.
Was?
If you have GNU Parallel
installed.
Parallel. Haben wir nicht.
Keine Ahnung. Das ist immer. Das ist
übelster Abfuck in Bash.
Das mach ich nicht,
Leute. Das mach ich nicht.
Kannste knicken. Da hab ich jetzt keinen Nerv drauf.
Ich.
Also ich mein, was wir machen können ist.
Wir können.
Also okay. Okay. Ich hab ne Idee,
Chat. Wir machen das so. Guck mal.
Wir machen das so. Wir machen einfach zwei
Schleifen. Wir machen
einfach zwei Schleifen. Guck mal.
Wir lassen das hier drin.
Mit nem und hinten dran.
Ganz normal.
Das. Das. Das.
Ja komm. Lass. Einfach mal.
So. Und.
Das sind jetzt nur
1000. Packt er denn. Packt er denn 1000?
Hat er 1000 gepackt, ohne
abzukacken? Ne. Auch.
Auch nicht. Oh. Fuck.
Packt er 100?
Okay. 100 schafft er.
100 schafft er.
So. Okay. 100 schafft er.
Theoretisch könnten wir jetzt ne Nested-Schleife machen.
Aber das ist halt richtig bescheuert.
Das würde ich natürlich mal. Also wir könnten
ne Nested-Schleife machen.
In der Zeit wär die normale Schleife durch. Ne.
Die war richtig langsam.
Wir können ja. Ist T-Max drauf?
Ne. Hätte ich gesagt, wir können ja.
Ah. Wir können uns mehrfach einloggen.
Machen wir das doch einfach mal.
Ja. Wir loggen uns mehrfach rein.
Ja. Ohne was. Ohne was
zu leaken. Hier oben machen wir die normale
Schleife. Ohne
Wait und alles. Du. Echo.
Das. Leute.
Das funktioniert überhaupt gar nicht.
Weil. Wir müssen
wahrscheinlich sogar noch ein Sleep machen.
Irgendwie sowas.
Und dann ein Curl dahinter.
Weil ich hab's mir noch hier aufgeschrieben.
Hier. Curl.
Break. Wahrscheinlich müssen wir noch
ein Sleep machen.
Irgendwie. Machen wir mal. Irgendwie 10
Millisekunden oder so.
Dass es überhaupt funktioniert.
Das ist richtig langsam.
Leute. Richtig langsam.
Ich glaub das wollen wir so nicht
haben. Okay. Also
was wir probieren können ist.
Wir nehmen das gleiche
was ich eben hab.
Sleep.
Sleep 0.01
So.
Da machen wir 100 Stück.
Von.
Schade dass es nicht 1000 geht.
Das wäre deutlich einfacher.
Müssten nicht eigentlich nur alle Prozesse aus
Netz der.
Ähm.
Nee. Das ist ja der Sinn an Portnocking.
Das ist.
Oh die VM ist übrigens gleich weg.
Leute.
Ah nee. Wir haben ja neu gestartet.
Das ist ja gerade der Sinn von Portnocking.
Dass das nicht irgendwie schon
lauschen muss.
Was eigentlich komisch ist.
Wollte das nicht eigentlich.
Sollte das nicht standardmäßig eigentlich schon.
Überhaupt nicht laufen.
Okay. Der nimmt halt einfach nix an.
Also wir können das.
Okay. Wir können eine Schleife machen.
100. Das sollte funktionieren.
Dann müssen wir jetzt das.
Das in Background schicken.
Ey. Das funktioniert nicht.
Nee. Ich mach kein. Leute.
Ich mach kein Bash Multithreading jetzt.
Ist mir zu doof.
Ich glaub das ist irgendwas auf Kernel Basis.
Wenn der. Wenn der. Der Kernel.
Ich bin mir da nicht sicher. Wenn der Kernel TCP Stack
quasi ein SYN Package sieht.
An diesen Port.
Dann greift es dieser Nock D ab.
Und müssen wir uns mal ne Konfig davon angucken.
Und dann wird das irgendwie erst freigegeben.
Man kann das glaube ich machen.
Über IP Tables regeln.
Das es dann erst durchgeleitet wird.
Keine Ahnung.
Leute. Das ist über 10 Jahre her.
Wo ich sowas mal gemacht hab für SSH.
Also okay. Wir sind jetzt.
Wir sind jetzt bei 6000.
Also wenn man noch.
Wir brauchen halt einfach.
10 mal so lang jetzt noch.
Bis es durch ist.
Also 1337 war es anscheinend nicht.
Wir können schon mal gucken.
Es ist ja noch nicht offen.
Das war es offensichtlich nicht.
Wie die Lösung wäre.
Ah guck mal.
Port 7001 ist es anscheinend.
Hat funktioniert.
Müssen wir uns gar keine Gedanken drüber machen.
Okay Port 7001 ist es.
Also entweder Port 7000 oder Port 7001.
Je nachdem wie lahm das ganze gewesen ist.
Aber ich tippe auf Port 7001.
Also hat.
Also meine Lösung war.
Netcat.
Also meine Lösung war im Endeffekt das hier.
Die billige Brute Force Variante.
Von Port 1.
Bis Port 65536.
Ähm.
Ein TCP SYN Package schicken.
An Local Host.
An den jeweiligen Port.
Vom Schleifendurchlauf.
Und das wars.
Wir müssen mal gucken ob es funktioniert.
Es hat funktioniert.
Das reicht.
Und jetzt wollten wir noch heraus kriegen.
Welcher Port es genau ist.
Und es ist dieser Port gewesen.
Also entweder Port 7001 oder Port 7000.
Ich tippe mal auf Port.
Ich tippe mal auf Port 7001.
Das das mit dem Sleep funktioniert hat.
Also wer sich hier das nochmal angucken will.
Wie es funktioniert.
Schleife von 1 bis 65536.
Schau mal.
Netstat.
Taucht da nicht auf.
So also Schleife 1 bis 65536.
Dann IP ausgeben.
Wo wir gerade sind.
Dann netcat-z.
Ich weiß gar nicht was z ist.
Wahrscheinlich nur SYN Package schicken oder sowas.
Ich hab das einfach mal straight from Arch Wiki.
Copy pasted.
Dann auf Local Host.
Den Port vom jeweiligen Schleifendurchlauf.
Dann 10 Millisekunden sleepen.
Wobei das übrigens auch davon abhängt.
Welches Sleep man hat.
Ich bilde mir ein.
Die ganz ganz alten Sleeps in der Bash.
Die konnten nur sekundenweise sleepen.
Und nicht Millisekunden mäßig.
Das geht schon ganz lange.
Millisekunden.
So dann machen wir 10 Millisekunden sleep.
Und danach machen wir einen Curl.
Und wenn das Curl funktioniert hat.
Dann brechen wir die Schleife ab.
Das heißt der Schleifendurchlauf bricht an dem Port ab.
Wo es funktioniert hat.
Also Port 7000.
Also höchstwahrscheinlich Port 7001.
Es könnte auch Port 7000 gewesen sein.
Weil vielleicht waren die 10 Millisekunden nicht genug.
Ich tippe auf Port 7001.
Weil dann ging es halt einfach.
Gut. Check my solution.
Korrekt.
Avesom.
Gepackt.
Was machen wir jetzt?
Die easy Sachen haben wir durch.
Haben wir noch Medium offen?
Oh ja was ist das hier?
Kubernetes Pod Crash.
Haben wir das schon gemacht Chat?
Kubernetes Pod Crashing?
Wie können wir das noch nicht gemacht haben?
Weil es new ist.
Pepega Leute.
Das haben wir garantiert noch nicht gemacht.
Weil von den ganz neuen haben wir nur das hier gemacht.
Und das hier bisher.
Und das das.
Spannend mit MisterJasord.
Spannend mit MrJasord.
Na lasst uns mal gucken ob ich da heute
Fifet
Kennenamen Kopf für habe.
Kubernetes Zeug zu machen.
Ich mach auf der Arbeit schon hauptsächlich Kubernetes.
Weiß ich nicht ob haben noch Kubernetes Zeug noises noch mache.
Nein gut.
Lassies wieiset mal angucken.
Was notchond man vorhaben.
Also Info .
Es gibt zwei Pods,
Einen Podlogger
und einen pott lockt schipper beide im default namespace also so weit so gut leider hat der
lockt schipper ein problem der crash stimme und dem der lockt schipper darf nicht auf dem auf den
locker was der lockt schipper hat ein problem und es ist ihm verboten zu sehen was der locker
sah ich gehe davon aus sie möchten wir sagen dass der lockt schipper nicht auf den locker
richtig zugreifen kann oder umgedreht could you help fix lockt schipper ok also wir sollen den
lockt schipper reparieren wir können die startung
von den pots abfragen mit cubectl get pots okay seriously ich glaube wenn das die einzige hilfe
ist die man für kubernetes bekommt das hätte man auch gewusst wenn man den rest lösen kann gehe ich
mal von aus so und dann wir sollen nicht das kubernetes jammer zeug ändern für den lockt
schipper pott und wir sollen sudo machen wenn wir uns einloggen so interpretiere ich das mal so und
am ende sollen wir checken
dass das okay dass das running ist alles klar oh shit man will ich wird es jetzt echt geben das
ist entweder easy oder abfacke ich weiß es jetzt schon wir machen das jetzt beim kuban eten stellt
die frage ist ja immer noch ist es kubernetes kubernetes kubernetes kubernetes kubernetes
gates wie das manche nennen was ich übelst dämlich finde alle kennt ihr leute die kubernetes
nennen also nicht ausgeschrieben k8s das mache ich auch es gibt leute die sagen ernsthaft gates
das hört an wie aids also richtig bescheuert welches os ist das arch linux by the way use ich
guck du solltest auch arch linux nutzen weil arch linux das einzig wahre die einzig wahre linux
distribution ist aber mit arch linux allein wäre es nicht viel weiterkommen musste erst mal einrichten
also das ist i3
also winrar
3 wm und falls du genau wissen willst wie die configs aussehen dann findest du das hier auf
shithub das server da ja ok auf geht's oh man wie gesagt ich weiß jetzt schon es wird entweder wie
viel zeit haben wir eigentlich 20 minuten ok ok moment ich weiß jetzt schon es wird entweder easy
oder abfang ok cube ctl geht ohne wir haben nicht mal autocomplete für cofac kaputt ok pass
mal auf check my solution was jetzt war die nicht so genau was los ist
easy
geil weiß wir sind wir sind top 1 leaderboard das scheint nicht so ganz ranking das war gucken
wo sind wir sind wir sind für ein ranking also hier packt irgendwas ranking an dem
welches haben wir gerade gemacht
buenos aires 31 sekunden best time wieder steht nicht von wem wir haben die bestseller 30 ich
vermute da ist irgendwas kaputt seriously irgendwas ist da kaputt weil es sollte nicht einfach einloggen
und es geht ich würde sagen wir machen das noch mal und gucken uns das in ruhe an weil das wird
das wird es nicht gewesen sein auch sehr gute idee sehr gute idee ist blick so ja ja sehr gute
idee muss man das muss man das irgendwie sourcen oder irgendwie in der datei schreiben oder ich
glaube das kann man ich glaube das kann man sich die besser c h h und mit einem source irgendwie
so ich habe das vor 33 jahren oder so meine besser c eingetragen was man kurz gucken wo bloß
cube ctl ja ha ha leute ich gucke einfach aus meinen dort falls ab dann ist das ist das ja
eigentlich kein beschiss so aufs liebke bettke aws macht bettke gerade das immer okay alles klar
ach so ein cube ctl getpods ging ja gar nicht also sudo soll
ich glaube ich habe es schon mal verstanden ich habe es schon mal verstanden ich habe es schon mal
ich habe es schon mal verstanden ich habe es schon mal verstanden okay cube ctl getpods minus
sie ist auf euro okay das ist bestimmt ein bug leute kann das sein dass das irgendwie wenn du
wenn du zu schnell auf checksolution klicks dass der pott noch keine chance hatte zu failen
irgendwie so was das können wir das können wir es jetzt sowas auf twitter posten er ist gut
dass ihr das geklemmt habt das können wir eben auf twitter posten
dass das irgendwie etwas verbugt ist gerade verbugt also log shipper crasht okay da war
jetzt erstmal source cube ctr oh ne haben wir keine bash completion abt abt abt ins
oh man wir können hier nicht wir können hier bash wir können hier nichts installieren ist
schon installiert oder auch ach so ups sie hat funktioniert ctr wir haben doch keine
bash completion geladen wartet mal source wo liegt das etc bash completion die best d oder
im moment completion die ist es nicht das sind die kommen einfach best completion sourcen ich
glaube ich habe das das habe ich glaube ich noch nie noch
nie vorhanden gemacht bringt das jetzt was club ctl
club ctl get trotz minus a nice und okay wir haben auch so kompliziert leute wir haben wir
haben eigentlich schon gewonnen solange wir club ctl auto komplett haben eigentlich ist
die sache ist gelaufen easy ich call es jetzt einfach schon mal easy easy easy easy okay ich
also was eigentlich kaputt ist also das mal gucken so der hier ist kaputt log shipper also
gucken wir uns mal an club ctl get trotz log shipper minus oh ja mal gucken wir uns das
mal ja gucken wir uns mal an also was ist was macht der log shipper denn der log shipper benutzt
sein image log shipper v3 commands user bin python log shipper pile gut das ist schon mal
wahrscheinlich nicht das problem dann club ctl logs log shipper einmal in power camp log shipper
das kann auch keiner lesen was ex exception when calling core v1 api read names will er auf die
kubernetes api zugreifen der log shipper das sieht ein bisschen so aus auf die also auf den den den den
also auf den den den den den den den den den den den den den den den den den den den den den den den
eigentlich ein kubernetes cluster ab beend punkt kannst kaos cash bla bla bla hier
response body jahne will auf die kubernetes abi zugreifen warum möchte ein log schiff auf
die kimoto was auch immer das er nicht das problem api version failure message first
ist forbidden user system und da habe ich kein bok entweder es ist ein problem mit dem service account
das ist oder nee ich weiß es ich weiß die haben dort die am netzwerk die haben
ich kann ja nicht mal reden alle die haben network policies wahrscheinlich
drin ok die wollen ich wollen hier richtig hart hat coachy bane network ich
dachte ich man schreibt das groß network network policies übrigens nur so als als
kleiner kuba nie des tipp wenn ihr keinen bock habt alles im detail
hinzuschreiben und einfach nur überblick wollt macht immer minus a hinten dran
minus a und minus groß a ist für für alle namespaces zum listen meint shit
okay es ist schon mal nicht das was ich gedacht habe vielleicht auf die falsche
api wegen deployment port replik jetzt gerade alles sein ja ja ja ja du hast
recht wir müssen uns mal ein weihermann variablen angucken für diesen pott
habe ich doch hier schon jammer kriegt er irgendwelche environment variablen
ich hasse das kuba netz jammel so zu lesen ein wein und nix oder irgendwie
mount oder so hat da auch nicht auch doch secret service account ok ist deutsch
aha guckte mal hier guckte mal hier mount path service account name kuba netz
api access
also der der der der der der der der der der der der der der der der der der der der der der der
also nicht der service account heißt so sondern der mount der dann im import
irgendwie als irgendwie volume muss ich so glaube volume nach ja genau hier das
wird gemountet in dem port mit file mode 420 als config map wird das
gemountet ok gut daran müssen wir aber wahrscheinlich nichts machen das sieht
auch okay aus
welcher service account ist es denn hier überhaupt hier service account
lockshänder okay jetzt weiß ich aus dem kopf nicht
weiterwartet kyu ctl wir lassen uns mal alles service governments anzeigen gibt
gibt's das ding da lockshänder s ok jetzt service account lockshänder so das
hier sind die
00 helps
die definition vom service account so also wenn ich das jetzt richtig verstehe unser problem hat
überhaupt nichts mit dem logger zu tun der logger ist vollkommen egal den logger habe ich nicht mal
reingeguckt der log shipper will an die kubernetes api und crasht weil er nicht an die kubernetes
api kommt das ding läuft unter irgendeinem service account und jetzt halt die frage also network
policies haben sie nicht jetzt halt die frage haben die irgendwelche anderen user wie heißt
dieser kram noch mal roll roll bindings heißt es glaube ich das ist ja das ist eines der parts von
kubernetes den ich echt so das ist sowieso zu der entgegner das kann das geht mir immer voll
auf den sack wenn damit irgendwas ist okay da muss ich mal kurz gucken also nach was
ich
wie ging das jetzt noch mal kubernetes service account vermischt ich glaube es heißt roll binding
heißt es glaube ich er back genau genau ja mach ein describe das ist eine gute idee leute übrigens
wenn ihr wollt ne ihr dürft backseaten so viel ihr wollt in diesen streams get describe log shipper
jetzt muss ich wieder pod machen log shipper what the fuck
pod sender
und boxen
das habe ich legit noch nirgends wo gelesen bisher was das moment hier in ein eigenes fenster auf
send box Change Limits
nee da kommt der fehler nicht her
pepsi overflow
Also ich bin keine ahnung was das was das ist also der stream ist noch da oder
Schalke hallo hallo schalke schalke
wo da vorn
vodafone
vodafone frames gedroppt
vodafone ist wieder in dem element alter
so ein schrott provider man
Okay, ich habe jetzt ehrlich gesagt keine ahnung genau woran das liegt
aber ich tippe also weil das ding ist dass das will eindeutig zur kuba nettes api zum zum
cluster endpunkt und er darf nicht
so und man kann das einschränken aber das ist echt das ist echt wirklich der der kuba net das entgegner
service account roll bindings und cluster roll und sowas aber was haben wir dann hier moment
cluster cluster klingt gut
ctl get oder
ja kaum cluster cluster roll
meines
ja ist ja gut man
Grab minus
lockt schipper
guck mal
cluster roll geld cluster roll
lockt schipper
also da weiß man jetzt natürlich bescheid wir kommen edit edit edit
ist direkt einfach zugegangen gerade
Leute, ich fürchte, das Ding hat
gerade den Abgang gemacht, den AWS.
Ich glaube, das hat gerade den Abgang
gemacht. Oder nicht?
Doch, das hat gerade
den Abgang gemacht.
Ja, dead, Leute.
Es ist dead.
Wir müssen
nochmal von vorne anfangen.
Check Solution. Fuck. Ja, wir hätten
Check Solution machen können.
Vielleicht hätte es jetzt einfach
funktioniert.
Ich meine, Leute, wir haben schon die Bestzeit
für Kubernetes
Stills.
Ich weiß nicht, bei Check Solution
können wir nicht mal ausprobieren. Ich habe ja schon reloaded.
Na toll.
Wie war das mit Cube CTL?
Das müssen wir jetzt gleich am Anfang machen.
Das hier.
Cube CTL und dann
Bash Completion sourcen.
Guck mal,
macht ziemlich nice
Coggers Loading.
Es ist
AWS. AWS ist gerade
nicht so schnell.
Aber ich verstehe es schon.
Ich meine, das ist alles kostenlos
und
Performance kostet in der Cloud
immer Geld. Deswegen ist doch alles
in Ordnung. Ich finde es toll, dass es den Service
hier gibt.
So, Open.
Okay, sudo
minus i.
Cube CTL. Jetzt haben wir das gleich mal
richtig. Bash.
Und jetzt
Source etc.
ETC Bash
Completion.
Cube CTL get
Pots minus A.
Okay. Also, wo sind wir stehen geblieben?
Cube CTL get
Cluster Rolls?
Cluster
Rolls?
Oder Roll Bindings?
Oh, das ist echt
ganz, ganz eklig hier.
Und dann ist das Ding,
das mit Lock Shipper Cluster
Roll.
Äh, nee, Quatsch.
Und jetzt habe ich gesagt,
und jetzt habe ich gesagt, wir
editieren das direkt. Okay.
Ah, ich glaube,
ich weiß, was passiert ist. Ich glaube, ich habe
Steuerung W gedrückt, um das Wort
zu löschen. Dann ist das Browserfenster zugegangen.
Aber das erklärt nicht, warum es
nicht wieder aufgegangen ist.
So, und jetzt hören meine
Kubernetes Skills aus dem Kopf
echt auf.
Kubernetes
Cluster Roll.
RPEXs.
Kubernetes Cluster
Roll. RPEXs.
Ja, okay.
Rules,
RPEXs, Resources, Namespaces,
Pots, Logs,
Verbs.
Was auch immer.
Ja, genau, genau.
Roll and Cluster Roll.
Define Permissions.
Define Permissions
Cluster.
Define, ja, ja, ja, ja.
Okay.
Okay, das ist ja soweit, soweit klar.
Resources, Pots.
Ja, Moment, wir
wollen nicht, wir, wir
wollen ja an die Kubernetes API selbst.
Indicates
the Core API Group.
Meine Güte, das ist so ultra kompliziert
immer gemacht. Also, was ich
hier schon mal, was ich hier schon mal verdächtig finde, dass die hier
Get, Watch und List drin haben und hier steht nur
List. Aber das
muss nicht wirklich viel heißen. So.
Und hier, nein, okay, nee,
hier haben sie nur Get und List.
Update. Moment, was gibt's denn da eigentlich
alles? Im Log.
Im Log steht drin, dass er nicht auf die
API kommt, weil er forbidden
ist. Was weiß ich hier?
Oh, guck mal, es gibt hier sehr viele Verbs.
Die machen wir jetzt einfach mal alle rein.
Okay. Was gibt es denn alles
für, für Verbs?
Steht das hier irgendwo?
Was sind Verbs überhaupt, man?
Also, Verben, ja, aber, aber in
die Form, ach, in der Form von
Get Request oder sowas, hä?
Verbs.
Also, das habe ich jetzt nicht gesehen. Ich kann es
jetzt zeigen. Warte mal. Guck mal hier
in den Logs.
Alter, was?
Wie, I? What?
Ähm, Logs.
Äh, Log,
Logshipper.
So, da erzählt er nur,
dass dieser User,
dieser User forbidden ist.
Ja, da kann er
Get Resource Pots.
Alter, was ist der
Neue los, äh?
List of Kubernetes Verbs.
Okay, alles.
Let's go.
Oh, ich stand das nicht.
Da gibt es doch, da gibt es
doch bestimmt irgendeine
ordentliche Liste, oder?
Elite?
Ja, komm, scheiß drauf. Zack.
Der kriegt
jetzt einfach alles. Edit.
Verbs. Egal.
What the fuck?
Warum bricht der, warum bricht der das Edit immer ab?
Was ist das für ein Scheiß, man?
Ah, ich raste aus.
Ist das schlimm?
Okay, Paste.
Okay, okay.
Ah, ah, okay. Escape. X.
Okay, Roll edited.
Nice.
Wir haben die Roll geedited.
Und
okay, da geht immer noch nicht.
Das kann aber sein,
dass der neu gestartet
werden muss.
L.
Und?
Geht das jetzt?
Es geht, oder?
Ich, ich, ich würde sagen, es tut.
Ja, das war's.
Easy.
Ich bin mir zwar nicht hundertprozentig sicher, was ich gemacht habe,
außer alle möglichen Access erlaubt überallhin, aber okay.
Nice, okay, wir haben es gefixt.
Top.
Ich weiß zwar nicht genau, was es jetzt gewesen ist, aber wir haben einfach möglichst viele Rechte erlaubt und, und nice, okay.
Was auch immer.
Leute, Kubernetes-Experte am Start.
Senior Kubernetes-ViFET-Experte am Start hier.
Lauter Fehlermeldung wäre die offensichtliche Lösung die
Zuordnung des Pods zu der richtigen Gruppe.
Mein...
Ja,
keine Ahnung, ich habe...
Also, ich bin mir nicht ganz sicher, warum das jetzt geht.
Wir können mal, wir können mal, ähm,
Clues gucken.
Okay, als Root sollen wir uns die...
Ah, wir sollen den Pod describen.
Okay, Chat, ihr hattet recht, ich habe den Pod nicht described, ich habe, glaube ich, mit, ich habe erst Logs geguckt und dann, ja, mit Definition geguckt, aber komm, komm, aufs Gleiche raus, okay, also, das haben wir sowas, sowas in der Richtung aber auch gemacht, next, you can view Logshipper Pod Configuration Describe Command to see the service, ja, das haben wir auch rausgekriegt, ich glaube aber um fünf Ecken irgendwie, weil, nee, das haben wir in der Logmeldung gesehen, in der Logmeldung stand das mit Service Account,
drin, look role binding, cluster role, service account is attached, get cluster role, das haben wir gemacht und dann sollen wir was machen, edit, okay, edit cluster role, das haben wir auch gemacht, ach, hier, guck mal, hier erklärt er auch was, WIM Editor, you can use control, ja, da hatte ich wahrscheinlich auch Probleme mit,
und danach muss man den Logshipper restarten, das mussten wir nicht machen, der ging einfach von sich aus, wahrscheinlich haben wir ein gutes Timing erwischt, dass der gerade wieder am Crashen war und sich neu gestartet hat, oh, Leute, das reicht, ich mache keins mehr heute, es ist genug, genug, genug Kubernetes, äh, oh, ja, wir haben jetzt noch eine halbe Stunde Zeit, wir können nochmal kurz checken, ob es irgendwas Interessantes auf YouTube zu gucken gibt, ähm, ich muss gerade mal gucken,
ja, war gerade irgendwas auf meinem Handy zu sehen, Sekunde, oh, ja, ja, ah, okay, ähm, ja, was auf Clips umstellen, was habt ihr denn geklippt, was habt ihr denn geklippt, ah, wow, huge fake E-Mail Adresse leak, so, Clips, ah, das hier oben muss man abhaken, warum das überhaupt da ist, verstehe ich nicht,
okay, eine Million IQ, Kubernetes Senpai,
Solves, setze auf das CTF in less than a minute, ja, Solves vor allem, ja, richtig, richtig gesol, komplett gesolvt habe ich das, ich hatte heute auch ein sehr schönes Kubernetes Problem, und zwar hatte ich Pods, die im Terminating State feststecken, weil sie einem Node zugewiesen waren, den es nicht mehr gab, okay, kann man das nicht irgendwie clean upen, wüsste ich aber aus dem Kopf auch nicht, kann auch, kann auch bei Kubernetes irgendwie so stale,
so aus, dass sie irgendwie aufräumen, aber aus dem Kopf hätte ich auch keine Ahnung, lasst uns doch mal kurz auf YouTube gucken, ob es noch irgendwas Spannendes gibt, für die letzte halbe Stunde, weil noch eine weitere Challenge fange ich heute nicht an, das kriege ich geistig heute nicht mehr auf die Reihe, ich hätte echt mal, gibt es, wisst ihr, eine Sache, die es echt zu wenig aktuell auf YouTube gibt, leider, leider, ich finde, das sollte nie aufhören,
Resitas mit Untertitel, besser, besser, super, ey, du, einfach der Beste, das ist einfach der Beste, ey, das ist einfach der Beste, ey, ich könnte mir das jeden Tag einmal angucken, das komplette Video,
das, das Original,
das Original, ihr wollt gerade sagen, das Original geht ewig, das geht, glaube ich, eine Viertelstunde oder so, wo er erzählt, wo er irgendwie seine, seine Nudelfannen ins Meer geschmissen hat und sowas,
beste Mini-PC für Fernseher, was ist das, und anhand von was, also eine Sache, die in Deutschland halt nicht funktioniert, aber die international eine Zeit lang auch sehr beliebt war, sind diese Hitler-Reacts-Videos,
wo sie diese Szene aus der Untergang nehmen und da gibt es ja auch alles Mögliche, Hitler uses Docker oder, oder Crashs Kubernetes-Cluster und, und alle möglichen Dinger, das, das ist halt auf Deutsch nicht lustig, wir verstehen, wir verstehen halt, was die sagen, so, und wir wissen da auch historisch ein bisschen besser Bescheid, aber das ist international sehr beliebt, so als YouTube-Clip,
wenn Postgres dann, Postgres ist Pog.
Oh, nee, das ist mir zu high IQ jetzt.
Ich glaube, ja, ja, glaube ich auch, El Resitas ist für Spanier wahrscheinlich auch nicht lustig, ja, gehe ich auch von aus, ja, denke ich, denke ich auch, wobei ich, wobei ich gehört habe, dass der Kerl so einen krassen Dialekt hat, dass den auch Spanier nicht richtig verstehen.
Wir haben auf der Arbeit einen Spanier, also externer eingekaufter Spanier, wenn ich das nächste Mal in einem Call bin, muss ich ihn fragen, ob er El Resitas kennt.
Der ist auch so ungefähr in meinem Alter, würde ich sagen, also, der sollte sich so mit Internet-Memes auch auskennen und dann frage ich ihn mal, ob El Resitas als, als Spanier, ob das lustig ist, wenn man das, wie mit den Untertiteln, ja, die Story, die, die Story, die er erzählt, eigentlich ist die Story total belanglos und doof, ne, aber mit seinem Rumgelache ist das halt geil, also, das Original El Resitas-Videos, da erzählt er, dass er in irgendeinem Restaurant am Strand gejobbt hat,
und ihm der Koch erzählt hat, er soll die dreckigen Pfannen sauber machen, ins Meer hängen, also ins Meer hängen, um sauber zu, sauber zu werden, und da hat er halt die Pfannen ins Meer gehängt und dann kommt er halt am anderen Tag morgens, glaube ich, wieder und es war halt Flut und die Pfannen sind weggespült gewesen, so.
Das ist halt die ganze Essenz aus dem, eigentlich aus dem, aus dem Original El Resitas-Video, aber man kann es sich trotzdem immer wieder geben.
So, was haben wir denn hier, was können wir uns jetzt mal angucken?
Was ist das?
Oh, wow, Wonka ist, Alter, was ist das für ein Laut?
Super demotivierte Softwareentwickler, ein Beispiel.
Chatge, wer von euch Softwareentwickler und nicht super demotiviert?
Also, ich muss sagen, seitdem ich meinen Job gewechselt habe, bin ich zumindest aktuell, das kann ja immer mal ein bisschen schwanken, aber aktuell bin ich nicht demotiviert.
Du?
Also, haben wir zumindest einen demotivierten Softwareentwickler.
Du bist kein, dann lassen wir das mal mit Softwareentwickler weg, seid ihr demotiviert, ja?
Also, habt ihr, habt ihr innerlich schon gekündigt oder nicht, die Demotivierten?
Pulumi, ich mag, ich mag Pulumi.
Ganz ehrlich, ich, mir ist es lieber als Terraform.
Leider sind diese ganzen IAC-Tools irgendwie alle, weiß nicht, nicht so geil, ja.
Ach, du hast sogar schon gekündigt, na dann.
Ich habe mit meinem Vater telefoniert und er meinte, ich habe, ihr müsst, ihr müsst, ich habe mich ja schon erzählt, ich habe mit dem in meiner Weise nicht allzu viel zu tun.
Und wir sind, wir sind jetzt auch nicht unbedingt so.
So die letzten Jahre über hatten wir jetzt auch nicht sonderlich viel Kontakt.
Hat, hat auch alles seine Gründe, aber, ja, zumindest, ich habe heute, ich habe mit meinem Vater telefoniert und er hat gemeint so,
oh, er ist so stolz auf mich, so, wie es so karrieremäßig läuft und sowas.
Und da habe ich mir auch gedacht, okay, allzu gut scheint er mich ja nicht zu kennen, wenn er ernsthaft denkt, ich mache Karriere.
Als wäre ich der krasse Karriere-Crinder, Mann.
Ich mache, wenn, wenn einer kein Bock auf Karriere-Crind hat, bin ich das, ja.
Ich bin so faul, was Karriere und sowas angeht.
Schritt 1, er muss Abo bei dir abschließen, ja.
Genau.
Okay, ich weiß, wie er es meint, ja, ich weiß, wie er es meint.
Ich meine, es ist ja, man muss ja schon sagen, es ist alles recht gut gelaufen die letzten Jahre über, ja.
Ich habe eine Arbeit, wo ich ganz gut verdiene.
Ich mache nebenbei ein bisschen.
Ich mache nebenbei ein bisschen YouTube und Twitch, wo man noch ein bisschen was rumkommt.
Also, es ist ja nicht schlecht oder so.
Aber es ist nicht so, als würde ich den krassen Karriere-Crind machen.
Da bin ich echt nicht der Typ für.
Was, was haben wir denn zum Ankommen?
Super demotivierte Softwareentwickler.
Warum sehen wir hier gerade so, ist das ein Schloss?
Ne, was ist das?
Das ist ein, ein Schwimmbad?
Ich weiß nicht, was.
Das hier ist, ist das eine Skipiste oder irgendwas für Segelflugzeuge?
Was haben wir denn sonst noch?
Guck mal hier.
Alter, nicht so laut, Mann.
Was ist denn?
Oh, einfach Zeitverschwendung.
Wie Linux insgeheim die Welt kontrolliert.
Ja, das hört an.
Reale Irrsinn.
Befachtes Klo in Köln.
Ja, mit, mit, mit Klos am Bahnhof oder falls, weiß nicht, ob das am Bahnhof ist.
Da habe ich ja, habe ich ja schon öfters mal die Story erzählt vom Hanauer Hauptbahnhof und dem Klo, was erst rebooten musste.
Impossible Doom Challenge.
Okay, komm.
Komm, wir gucken uns jetzt an, warum Softwareentwickler.
Demotiviert sind 10 Minuten, 10 Minuten Video labere ich locker 20 Minuten dazu.
Das heißt, das kriegen wir gerade so durch.
Max, hast du mal mit Ross mit was mit Ross?
Ich habe es mir mal mit Erthos gemacht, aber nicht mit Ross.
Was ist Ross überhaupt?
Oder oder er oder ist es Ross oder was ist?
Guck einfach das Postkreis Video.
Ich mache es mal auf.
Aber Simples.
Ich will mir jetzt kein.
High IQ Postkreis Zeug angucken.
Diese Middleware für Roboter.
Okay, keine Ahnung.
Nein, habe ich mir nie angeguckt.
So, zeige ich mal her.
Was hat er denn hier zu?
Oh, nee, Moment.
Ist das der Typ, der durch den Wald läuft?
Ach, das ist der Typ, der durch den Wald läuft.
Das haben wir doch das letzte Mal schon geguckt.
War das?
ZG, ich kann mich nicht mehr richtig daran erinnern.
Das war doch gar nicht schlecht, das letzte Video, was wir geschaut haben, oder?
Außer, dass es irgendwie ein bisschen verstörend war, dass er im Wald die ganze Zeit auf uns zugekommen ist.
Ich glaube, das war gar nicht so übel.
Deswegen kriege ich das auch noch empfohlen und vom Titel her passt es ja auch.
Moment.
Aus.
So.
Was?
Als Softwareentwickler kennst auch du das Problem.
Ab und zu ist man demotiviert.
Man hat keine wirkliche Lust zu arbeiten.
Ja, was nicht nur bei Softwareentwicklern übrigens so ist.
Was auch daran liegt, dass ein hoher Teil des Tages irgendwelche sinnlosen Meetings sind.
Oder irgendeinen anderen Scheiß, ja.
Also, ich finde es immer geil, wenn die dann rechnen, so nach dem Motto,
ah, das Projekt, das braucht so und so viel PT und da können wir einen Mitarbeiter dafür abstellen.
Was die aber alle nicht einrechnen ist, dass du nur 50% deiner Zeit überhaupt arbeiten kannst,
weil der Rest mit irgendwelchen Meetings voll ist.
Und das ist nicht übertrieben.
50% ist durchaus realistisch.
Ich weiß nicht, wie sieht es bei euch aus?
Also, ich habe, passt mal auf, Leute.
Machen wir jetzt mal, wo habe ich mein Handy hier?
Gestern.
Alles.
Und dann sage ich euch heute, okay.
Gestern.
Kalender.
Also, Chat.
Passt mal auf.
Gestern.
Okay, gestern.
Also, geht los.
Oh, ich mache die Musik wieder an.
Wobei, dafür brauchen wir, dafür brauchen wir eindeutig.
Okay.
Hast du auch genau dazu.
Also, gestern ging es los.
9.30 Uhr.
Bis 11.
Ich lese ein bisschen zu laut, das ist vielleicht.
Okay.
Also, ging los.
Gestern.
9.30 Uhr bis 11.
Sprint Review.
Ja, gestern waren wir super hyper agile.
Massive agile sind wir gewesen.
Wir haben den ganzen Tag quasi diagonal skaliert.
Hyper scaled haben wir.
Diagonal hyperscaled den ganzen Tag.
Also, 9.30 Uhr bis 11 Uhr Sprint Review.
Dann, nebenbei, nebenbei, ne, 9.30 Uhr bis 9.45 Uhr Daily Scrum.
Also, ihr merkt vielleicht, dass Sprint Review und Daily Scrum sich überschnitten haben, aber okay.
Dann, Team Daily, 10.00 Uhr bis 10.15 Uhr.
Dann, 11.00 Uhr bis 12.30 Uhr Sprint Retrospektive 1.
Dann, ähm, das kann ich euch so nicht vorlesen.
Ich sag aber, ich sag mal nur, 11.00 Uhr, das ist auch parallel jetzt, 11.45 Uhr bis 12.30 Uhr, ähm, Blockchain, Blockchain Operation, so.
Mehr kann ich euch nicht vorlesen.
Dann, geht's weiter.
14.15 Uhr bis 15.00 Uhr Sprint Retrospektive 2.
Und...
Ach ne, sorry Leute, das wurde abgesagt.
Das wurde abgesagt.
Die, die ist cancelled.
Sprint Retrospektive 2.
Dafür geht es weiter.
Um 14.30 Uhr bis 16.30 Uhr Sprint Planung für den nächsten Sprint.
War super agil, oder?
Also, im Prinzip habe ich angefangen von 9.30 Uhr bis, ja, eigentlich bis 16.00 Uhr, 16.30 Uhr, aber da bin ich mit 16.00 Uhr schon abgehauen.
Also, von 9.30 Uhr bis 16.30 Uhr.
Mehr oder weniger durchgängig gemietet.
Allerdings, stimmt das nicht ganz, weil es war ja immerhin von, sagen wir mal, 12.30 Uhr bis 14.00 Uhr, 15.00 Uhr, äh, 12.30 Uhr bis 14.30 Uhr waren keine Meetings.
In der Zeit habe ich was gegessen und wahrscheinlich mal kurz irgendwas anderes gemacht.
Also, sagen wir mal, eineinhalb Stunden hätte ich theoretisch was arbeiten können, wenn man da reinkommt.
Aber, im Prinzip war, sagen wir mal, 70% der Tag...
Das Tag des Tages war Mieten.
Okay, es wird jetzt nicht unbedingt besser.
Heute geht los mit was, was ich echt gut finde.
Heute, heute um 9.00 Uhr ging es wieder los.
9.00 Uhr bis 9.15 Uhr.
Gab es, gab es, ähm, Neuigkeiten aus unserem IT-Führungskreis.
Finde ich immer ganz gut, dass das quasi auch an die Leute verteilt wird, alles.
Ja, das gab es.
Ja.
Also, 9.00 Uhr bis 9.15 Uhr.
Dann geht es allerdings gleich weiter.
9.30 Uhr bis 9.45 Uhr, Daily Scrum.
Danach gibt es 10.30 Uhr bis 11.00 Uhr, Weekly Catch-Up Call.
Ist auch so ein geiles, geile Formulierung, ja.
Weekly Catch-Up Call.
Also, ich meine nicht Tomatensauce, sondern aufholen, Catch-Up Call.
Dann gibt es Gruppen, wöchentliches Gruppen-Meeting.
Dann gibt es wöchentliches Team-Meeting.
Und dann gibt es nochmal 15.00 bis 16.00 Uhr Austausch-Synch-Jur-Fix-Projekt mit Projektnummer.
So.
Heißt im Endeffekt, ich habe von, sagen wir mal, 16, sagen wir mal, ich würde 8 Stunden am Tag arbeiten.
Aber es sind, die Arbeitszeit ist ein bisschen weniger.
Aber gehen wir mal einfach von 8 Stunden aus.
Sagen wir mal von 16 Stunden an 2 Tagen.
Dann konnte ich vielleicht 3 arbeiten.
Nice, oder?
Pog.
Extremely Pog.
Und dafür kriege ich Geld.
Aber die wollen es so.
Und es ist auch okay, es ist auch ihr Recht, das so zu wollen.
Dann mache ich das auch so.
Richtig agile.
Massive.
Wie gesagt, wir haben den ganzen Tag Hyperscaled in alle Dimensionen, ja.
Wie lang geht der Sprint?
Eine Woche, zwei Wochen, drei Wochen, vier Wochen?
Nein.
Der geht, in der Regel geht er zwei Wochen bei dem Projekt.
Und wie viele der Meetings hättest du gebraucht?
Also unser Team, unser Team Daily finde ich immer ganz gut.
Den Rest hätte ich eigentlich nicht gebraucht.
Nee, nee, nee, nee.
Du hast hier, du hast hier was übersehen.
Ah ja, das ist nicht zwangsläufig schlecht, wenn das alles dazu passt.
Ja, hier kann ich auch.
Ich mache das, ich mache das manchmal auch ganz gerne, dass ich an dem Tag tatsächlich nach Frankreich gehe.
Wenn ich dann tatsächlich nach Frankfurt auf die Arbeit fahre, weil dann weiß ich jetzt schon, wenn die Meetings rum sind, kann ich einfach reinfahren.
Agile ist der, das kenne ich, das kenne ich.
Das kann sogar einer, ich will nicht sehen, ob es einer der originalen, ja doch, die kenne ich, die Präsentation, die ist gut.
Das ist einer der originalen Agile Manifest Dudes.
Frustriert dich das nicht, du überspielst das ja immer, wenn die wollen, macht sich das.
Na ja.
Also, sonderlich geil finde ich es ehrlich gesagt nicht, so viel zu mieten, aber ganz im Ernst, ich finde es auch nicht so schlimm, wie sich das vielleicht anhört, wenn ich mich da ein bisschen drüber lustig mache, weil es ist, es ist, es ist tatsächlich, ich sehe das genauso, wie ich das sage, die wollen das so haben, die bezahlen echt nicht wenig Geld dafür und wenn die, wenn die in eine Technik, ja, IT-Technik-Typ einstellen wollen, der kaum Technik macht, ist das okay.
Okay.
Also, ich finde, die Funktionen, die die man da in der Technik erfüllen, sind ja meistens eh irgendwelche private Bastelleien und Projekte oder Sachen, die wir hier im Stream machen, wo es mich wirklich auch interessiert.
Das muss mich nicht unbedingt den ganzen Tag auf der Arbeit interessieren, was ich da mache und ich, ich setze mich, also ohne Mist, ich setze mich auch 6, 7 Stunden am Tag in Meeting, wenn mich da Leute einladen und meinen, ich muss da, muss da dabei sein.
Es soll sich bloß, und das kommt bei mir auf der Arbeit tatsächlich auch relativ selten vor, es soll sich nur keiner beschweren, dass das nicht, dass, dass andere Sachen nicht funktionieren.
Ich meine, ich habe nur...
Ich denke mir das ja nicht aus, dass ich das, also, wenn ich es mir, ich sag mal, sagen wir es mal so, wenn ich es mir aussuchen könnte, dann würde ich wahrscheinlich etwas weniger mieten, ja.
Das habe ich ja auch sogar im Vorstellungsgespräch gesagt, dass ich das nicht gut finde, wie das auf der aktuellen Arbeit läuft und ich mir das anders wünschen würde, aber, nun ja, natürlich hat man dann gesagt, ja, ja, bei uns ist das viel besser.
Wobei, sie haben nicht gesagt, bei uns ist das viel besser, sie haben gesagt, ja, natürlich gibt es bei uns auch irgendwie Meetings, aber wir versuchen ja immer zu beenden, wenn, ja, wenn der Zweck des Meetings erfüllt ist, naja, also, das stimmt schon, die meisten Meetings gehen manchmal ein bisschen kürzer, aber es sind halt trotzdem so viele.
Es gibt sicherlich noch viel, viel mehr, ja, ja, bin ich, ich gehe auch auf viele nicht hin, also, ich habe ganz viele Termine im Kalender drin stehen, wo ich gar nicht weiß, was es ist, bzw.
was sie da eigentlich machen, da gehe ich dann auch nicht hin, ja, ja, also, wenn es danach geht, hätte ich ja quasi den ganzen, also, ich könnte von Terminen her, wenn ich keinen Bock hätte, was zu machen, ich könnte echt den ganzen Tag mieten und ich habe auch teilweise Tage, da habe ich vier oder fünf, und das ist jetzt echt kein Witz, vier oder fünf Paralleltermine, aber das meiste irgendwelche Infosachen, wo ich nicht weiß, was sie wollen und ich hingehe.
Story Mappings, jetzt wird es aber richtig hyperskaliert agil, so, also, wir wollten uns eigentlich, eigentlich wollte ich mir noch das Video angucken.
Zeit.
Jetzt habe ich euch, jetzt habe ich euch mein Meeting-Tagebuch vorgelesen.
Ne, wir gucken uns, Chat, ich lasse das auf, wir gucken uns das Video nicht an.
Ich muss in sieben Minuten ins Bett, wenn ich jetzt die bestbezahlten Ausbildungen, okay, da bin ich, da bin ich mal gespannt, das skippen wir jetzt schnell durch.
Das skippen wir jetzt schnell durch.
Okay, Zeit mal her.
Okay.
Platz 10.
Für was?
Okay, Immobilienkaufmann, gefolgt, was, keine, was stand da, keine, Immobilienmakler, ach, keine Ausbildung, wie zum Teufel kann was, was keine Ausbildung gibt, zu den bestbezahlten Ausbildungen gehören?
Ach ne, das kann man werden danach wahrscheinlich.
Okay, was, was kommt als nächstes?
Äh, ich habe es verpasst.
Ah, YouTube.
Ja, was denn jetzt?
Ach, Mau, ach je, ach ja, muss man gucken.
Maurer, okay, nice.
Gut, die brauchen halt wie verrückt Leute, ne.
Kaufleute für Versicherungsfinanzen.
So, als nächstes haben wir...
...7 Monate.
Wir bleiben erstmal beim Thema Versicherungen, denn auf Platz Nummer 7 liegen die Sozialversicherungsveranstalter.
Wer macht denn sowas?
Platz 6 geht auch ziemlich schnell, da warten neben...
Das ist, die, die, die Tabs sind doof.
Was ist das? 7?
Platz 6 geht auch...
Was zum, was, ah, das Video ist so dumm geschnitten, das gucke ich mir nicht an.
Da findet man nicht die wichtigen Infos, man muss das Video tatsächlich gucken.
Oh ja, der hat mir jetzt noch gefehlt, ja.
Microsoft so x-expert talks about Windows 10.
Okay, top.
Ich brauche jetzt, Leute, ich brauche jetzt, bevor ich ins Bett gehe, noch eine Runde.
El Ricitas.
Ahi!
Es ist alt, das Video, okay, aber...
Windows 10.
Pero cuántos días en total, más o menos?
Más o menos.
De 45 años has podido trabajar un año?
Siete años.
Siete, por ahí, ya no más.
Der Microsoft-Pop.
Hasta hoy.
De 45 años, siete años.
Pero con descansos.
Con...
Ay.
Llevo lo primero que entraba, donde me colocaba, pidía el día de descanso ya.
Y me dice algo, yo, ha entrado usted y ya está pidiendo el día de descanso.
Sí.
Ich weiß, ich weiß, weil, hieß das Mira, die Touch-Ober-Fleche von Windows 8?
Das war der Beste, Alter.
Ay.
Te conviene que te entienda alguien más con el Touch-Ober.
Okay, Windows 10.
Ah, bueno, aquí está arriba.
La salsa del agua de la playa.
No, abajo.
Los espectadores.
Los espectadores, ah.
Las saques, te echas a la playa.
No es lo de Semana Santa que los narajos.
Y risitas, coge las 20 paelleras, las amarras y las entierras en el agua.
Y acuérdate, a donde las echas, que mañana tienes que ir a por ellas.
Y cuando salgo, era las dos de la noche, había bajado la marea.
La dejé amarrar, tal como me lo vio, la estiré.
Le puse un palo.
Y se llegó a la cocina, eran las dos y media de la noche.
Ricitas, ¿qué?
¿La has hecho?
Allí está jefe.
Acuéstate, que mañana a las ocho te llamo, para que vayas a recoger las paelleras.
Y me acuesto en su, allá para el restaurante que era el arroz.
Y me llama el cocinero.
Ricitas, ¿qué?
Ve por las paelleras.
Venga, que a las dos de la tarde ya están aquí.
Mira, el bañador.
En la chancla.
...todo despeinado, porque no me dio tiempo ni nada, ponerme las chanclas y el bañador.
Voy a la playa, había subido la marea.
Es ist nur wieder Selfie, schade, das.
Ey, du!
Había subido la marea y encontré una paella.
Y la encontré porque estaba la paella en la garra.
Entremetí entre las piedras de Chepillones en el faro.
Y cuando entré en el restaurante, bebé, el cocinero con una paella,
ya lo entró a la venta para ir...
Okay, ey, ich hab schon bessere Varianten gesehen.
Ey, ey, ohne Scheiß, Forst-Updates haben sich eigentlich gar nicht als so schlecht rausgestellt.
Wenigstens läuft jetzt kaum noch die Oma mit irgendwie nem fünf Jahre alten outdated Windows 10 rum.
Das ist ja schon mal so.
Ja, ja, also, da hab ich schon...
Oh, oh, was ist das? Was war das?
Linux... Kennen wir das schon?
Linux Guru talks about Linux Desktop.
Okay, komm mal, das ist so lang her, da kann mich schon gar niemand dran erinnern.
Más o menos.
De 45 años has podido trabajar sin años.
How many years of feelings... Okay.
Siete años.
Fünfzig Jahre.
Siete. Por ahí, ya, ya, ya.
Pero, pero, pero...
Hasta hoy.
De 45 años, siete años.
Has siete.
Pero con descansos.
Yo lo primero que entraba a donde me colocaba, pidía el día de descanso ya.
Y me dice algo, yo, ha entrado usted y ya está pidiendo el día de descanso.
Sí.
Te conviene que te entienda alguien más, porque para eso cobras.
Ah, bueno, ah, el que está arriba.
Estoy descubriendo la caza, la caza con agua de la playa, la caza con la playa.
¡Oh, chel!
Los espectadores, la caza que te echa a la playa.
Soy Pedro.
Pero, pero, pero, pero.
La caza que te echa a la playa.
Pero, pero, pero.
Pero, pero, pero, pero.
La caza que te echa a la playa.
¿Qué pedazo es esto?
De las Náuticas.
Las Náuticas.
No es lo de Semana Santa, que es los Naranjos.
Y Rizita coge las 20 paelleras, las amarra, y las entierra en el agua.
Y acuérdate, a donde las echas, que mañana tienes que ir a por ellas.
und morgen muss ich nach ihr gehen.
Und wenn ich rausgekommen bin, war es um halb neun Uhr,
da war die Maree runtergefallen.
Ich habe sie gelassen,
ich habe sie festgemacht, so wie ich sie gesehen habe,
ich habe sie gedreht,
ich habe ihnen einen Schlag gegeben
und ich bin in die Küche gekommen,
es war um halb neun Uhr.
Ich habe gesagt, was hast du gemacht?
Da ist der Chef.
Ich habe gesagt, achte auf,
morgen um acht Uhr
werde ich dich anrufen,
damit ich die Paellera holen kann.
Und ich habe mich auf den Süden gesetzt.
Ist klar, das ist die Ausrede, die bei jedem kommt,
wenn er Torrentlaufen hat.
Warum hast du Torrentlaufen?
Ja, ich muss die Linux-Distribution runterladen.
Ich habe mich auf den Süden gesetzt,
um das Restaurant zu öffnen, das das Arroz war.
Und dann hat der Küchenlehrer mich angerufen.
Ricita, was?
Geh in die Paellera.
Komm, um acht Uhr sind sie schon hier.
Schau, der Waschmaschine,
die Schankla,
alles ausgeschnitten,
weil es mir nicht Zeit gab,
die Schankla zu tragen
und den Waschmaschine.
Ja, genau.
Warum musst ich die Schankla runterladen?
Ich muss sie unterhalten,
damit ich sie nicht unterhalten kann.
damit ich sie unterhalten kann.
Ich muss sie unterhalten,
Sie sind ein Abo aus der Kampagne.
Das ist gut.
Die andere Kamera ist aus der Kampagne,
das ist ein Abo aus der Kampagne.
Viele Schüler,
der hat eine neue Kamera.
Eine neue Kamera,
und das ist die Kamera,
aber sie ist ein kleiner.
Ich habe sie gefunden, weil ich die Maillere in die Schale genommen habe.
Ich habe sie in die Schale genommen.
Und als ich in den Restaurants kam,
war der Koch mit einer Maillere.
Und dann kamen 20 Mailleren.
Dann kamen 40 Mailleren.
Das stimmt ja nicht.
Ohne Scheiß.
Vor sieben Jahren haben sie sich über Wayland lustig gemacht.
Und es funktioniert heute vieles immer noch nicht richtig.
Zum Beispiel in der VM ordentlich.
Die Linux-Variante war deutlich besser als die Windows.
Als der Windows-Risitos.
Alles klar.
Das muss jetzt zum Schluss nochmal sein.
Ich sehe, ihr seid schon alle im Bett.
Da gehe ich jetzt auch ins Bett.
Wir sehen uns die Tage, Leute.
Macht's gut, bis dann.
See you.